about mid at the end when you're doing
that lovely thing and you're looking to
each other's eyes
we all want a box or something because
well I was mainly cast because I can
make anyone look huge
extraordinarily short but yeah they
usually had some sort of ramp that I
would like walk up
somewhere near his face
should we should we stand up and show it
and I have like very high heels on right
now
that's actually quite a high ramp yeah
quite a bit of uh you know a steep
incline yeah
no listen uh of course with great action
here rules Come great action figures
ladies and gentlemen uh we've got some
here uh here oh no you've dropped your
hammer
so
there's yours have you seen this yet uh
not that particular one but it's the
likeness is incredible it is uncanny
isn't it gentleman it's
that's the uh slightly sedated version
isn't it and then you do an old thing
you press you here and you talk
[Applause]
I will strike you down he's angry so
there's you and then we'll just we'll
just get Natalie's action figure here
she's now they are almost
[Applause]
[Laughter]
exactly yeah children with hours fun
playing with those
they're gonna have a great time
what are you doing with those dolls
that's not a hammer
but you you look a bit distraught I got
your hat you're just like
[Music]